all right we're back again and it's
movie retrospective time just a little
bit of a heads up if the audio doesn't
sound quite as good as usual I mean it's
probably fine but if it's not a problem
here we've been having a little bit of
problem with the Yeti like we're having
a connection issue like to my Mac and
stuff like that it seems to be working
but it doesn't seem to be recognizing
this specific mic microphone so it's
like it seems to be recording and it
sounds passable but it might not sound
as good as usual yeah we used like three
different cables and but third one seems
to make a little bit of difference but
still not recognizing it as a Yeti maybe
it's a dirty contact we don't know yeah
so we're just gonna try and figure it
out but you know we had to get this
movie review done so I said well it's
working at least so let's kind of get on
it all right so the movie today that
we're going to do this is another one
from the 70s as I said my favorite very
favorite era of horror movies and this
is one that really kind of flies under
the radar a lot it's called let's scare
Jessica to death
now I remember seeing this when I was
maybe eight or nine years old I think I
saw it on TV or something like that and
I remember being a kid and it really
really creeping me out and then I didn't
see it for a really long time again but
I still remembered it like I remembered
some of the creepy imagery from it and I
had put it on the list to do for movie
retrospectives and then shudder who
seemed to read my mind at times mm-hmm
just put it up a couple weeks ago I was
pretty good it's like like I said I know
we kissed shudders ass all the time and
stuff but like it really is a good
service and it's like five bucks a month
yeah well the weird thing about it is
that pretty much every week they add at
least one movie that's on my retro
specialist like they like I had been
thinking about oh I want to do Don't
Look Now and Bing they added it yeah a
lot of good class he's a changeling Bing
they added it and it's like I've been
wanting to do let's get Jessica to death
being they out of it and I was like what
how do they know yeah it seems like
Netflix is competing with them because
Netflix has put up some of the old
classics too yeah they've put up a bunch
of old older movies too which you know
that's pretty cool because I think that
was something a lot of people I mean a
lot of people like the newer content
- but I think a lot of people are
complaining it's like oh you can still
get old movies but they still like mail
them to you like right back in the
[ __ ] but what if you want to see
poultrygeist one dark ages yeah yeah so
they'd seem to be doing better in that
department but like I said so I was very
very excited to see that they had added
this one because I haven't wanted to do
this one forever um so let's get on it a
little bit now you didn't really watch
it I think it was on you were in the
bronze watch on I was drinking and I was
like man I'm not really in the mood 70
stuff is usually slow burn that innit
this very much is yeah and if I got
other business going on and I'm you know
interacting with you know subscribers
and stuff online you know I started
texting down start messaging yeah you
should
tablet it so he's not really like yeah
and I'm looking up and I'm going on
man's another one we can burn out on we
can burn out on horror yeah I don't but
yeah I can depend on what type you know
7000 burn I can burn out on that after
while and I've noticed that if I didn't
grow up seeing it then I can't really
connect with it as well yeah if I was a
kid when I saw it huh you know see then
all sudden it kind of comes back to me -
Mike oh yeah I remember that might be
why I mean this movie came out in 1971
and in a lot of ways it was kind of like
it was almost ahead of its time and
here's an interesting thing about this
movie that I didn't know until I went
and researched a little bit about it but
that the original version of the
screenplay which was written by a guy
named Lee called chyme and the original
version of the screenplay was actually
called something like I drink hippy
blood and I was supposed to be like a
that feel like an exploitation type of
movie in a play on a second Street or
whatever now the guy that directed it
whose name was John Hancock not that one
that's a good man if you went like like
like you know I drink millennial blood
they were trying Rodrigue hipster blood
well they were trying to do something
like the the very famous like drive-in
movies I drink your blood I eat your
skin yeah you know so they were kind of
trying that he wanted to do something in
that vein but when the director got hold
of
like you know I like I kind of like this
concept I mean the original concept was
about a bunch of hippies and they go to
this Cove and then there's like a
monster in the water that picks them off
one by one right um so if you've seen
let's scare Jessica to death you'll know
that that's not really her movie ended
up being but he liked some of it and he
likes some of the characters he's like
can I have retool it and he really took
it in the complete opposite direction it
still has that 70s low-budget kind of
feel to it but he went more like this
phantasmagorical like dreamlike
psychological thriller type of thing
rather than making it like an
exploitation flick like it's not
particularly gory it's not you know it's
not exploited if really it's almost more
like you know what it it seems like it's
really influenced by Carmilla you know
the Sheridan life a new story which of
course was made into like daughters of
darkness and stuff like that and
actually if you like daughters of
darkness you would probably like this as
well you know spoiler alert this is a
vampire movie but not in a vampire movie
type away like you don't really know
it's a vampire movie until about halfway
through you just think there's some
creepy [ __ ] going on or that the
protagonist is crazy or she's like
imagining things are seeing ghosts or
something like that you don't really and
like I said it doesn't have a lot of the
like quote-unquote vampire tropes you
know like fangs and and most of it's set
in the daytime too like it's so it's not
like all night and there's like there's
creeping around so it's it's really
interesting that they went that
direction with it and like I said this
is a movie that I saw when I was a kid
like on cable and particularly the one
image of Emily the girl like coming out
of the water like in that wedding dress
and she's all pale and [ __ ] like that
and I remember that freaking me out like
a really lot so I was really happy like
it has you this whole scenes in it yeah
and I was like pretty creepy and when
you say it's a vampire movie but not in
a normal way it's kind of like saying
dead and buried is a zombie movie but
not in a normal
that's good that's a good analogy good
man that's a good analogy because yeah
dead and buried technically a zombie
with this technically a bit vampire
movie but not like 90 additional way not
a traditional vampire maybe yeah so
let's kind of talk a little bit about it
now the main character jessica is played
by Zora Lampert who I think I don't know
she was in a lot of other movies I think
she did a lot of TV and stuff like that
she's like a character actress now her
character in this has just gotten out of
a six-month stay in a mental hospital
for kind of something that's not you
know there you're implied that it was
like nervous breakdown or maybe she you
know tried to commit suicide or
something like that they don't really go
that much into it just that she has you
know recently been released since she's
kind of in a fragile mental state now
her husband Duncan he's a musician
within New York Philharmonic and he
thinks that they should get Jessica out
of New York City and like take her to
this remote creepy gothic mansion like
out on this little island in Connecticut
like a you know so she can get better I
guess so they're gonna go out there and
like do farming and stuff like that
which to me is really interesting that
whenever like in these movies and in our
books or whatever like whenever a woman
like gets out of a mental institution
everybody's like let's take her like out
and like isolate her and live nowhere
that will surely be good for her pencil
neck and it just never works that I
don't know what the same thing happened
like in the very famous short story the
Yellow Wallpaper well it's like you know
or well clearly you're crazy so let's
just lock you up in a bedroom and not
let you like talk to anybody
don't let the neighbors see you right
it's like I'm sure that will that will
really so the interesting thing too
about this one is that you know if you
read my blog or you read them but like
my other movie reviews and stuff like
that one thing I love about movies from
this period or you know whenever is
ambiguity like I love if you don't know
like if the creepy [ __ ] is really
happening or if like the protagonist is
just going Looney Tunes so yeah and you
it's funny and ambiguity falling out of
fashion as of late all you gotta do is
just listen to read reviews on some
movies you know the they don't like any
ambiguous
she's like in superhero movies well
superhero movies have like a different
yeah but back in the day or science
fiction but back in the day ambiguity
was part of the creep factor too
although honestly I feel like a lot of
indie horror has gone backward which
that's good cuz I like that I think it
makes it like a richer experience if you
don't really know some 70s ambiguity
also is kind of by accident I think yeah
this is I don't this was intentional
right this was 100% intentional because
I think the whole the whole thing of her
going out to this place you know and so
she's goes out there with her husband
and this friend of theirs named woody
like I said they're marginally hippie
they don't really look like hippies or
anything like that woody kind of looks
like a hippie he's got like the big
mustache and whatnot and he's like a
musician and [ __ ] but like um Duncan and
Jessica don't particularly look like
hippies they just look like normal
people of the era but so they go out to
this house and one of the first things
they encounter like with this house that
they bought or rented or whatever is
Jessica sees a girl sitting on the porch
and then she doesn't see her but she
doesn't tell anybody because she's like
well I just got a room ental Hospital
and if I'm seeing things then I don't
want them to send me back right so
there's this whole thing and then she
also has this kind of there's like
another layer of it too because she has
this whole thing where she's kind of
like death obsessed which is to me what
implies that she probably had tried to
commit suicide at some point in the past
even though they don't really explicitly
mention that because there's all this
stuff about you know they drive a hearse
like some hippies did um you know on the
way to the house they stop at a
graveyard so she can do some grave
rubbings because she's like really into
like making you know you would you did
the charcoal over the graves and like
tubes stuff like that and there's also a
seat they're really cool like a little
detail where you see them pushing
something into the back of the hearse
that looks like a coffin but then you
find out later that it's actually
Duncan's it's a cello or something like
that sees a musician but I like that
they kind of put that little detail in
there it's like oh you think it's a
coffin but later on you find out it's
not hmm
so she has this whole like death
obsession thing too
but she's trying to get better and so
when she does see creepy [ __ ] she keeps
it to herself but you know that because
you can hear like a lot of her internal
monologue you know they kind of say like
what's going on in her head and stuff
like that so she'll say stuff like you
know don't tell him you saw that like
act normal
you know and she'll say stuff like that
so the cool thing about her performance
in this this is a really good this is
one of the best depictions I think of
like mental illness that I've seen on
screen because you feel so bad for her
because you know what her internal
thought processes are you know her her
husband's kind of a douche and you know
that if she just says she saw something
he's gonna be like you're so crazy you
know what I mean so and there's that
whole thing too and particularly her
being you know a woman and stuff and you
know knowing a lot of a lot of women
have that thing where it's like you feel
like crazy syndrome right it's [ __ ]
be crazy you feel like you get
second-guessed all the time or and
things like that so you can kind of
relate to it in that way too even if she
wasn't mentally ill Jenny and I are old
enough to remember as kids what how bad
mental illness was stigmatized yeah in
the 70s and also in the 80s if you were
mentally ill if you had mental problems
especially like suicide you were crazy
yeah you're [ __ ] crazy and if you
were crazy they had a tendency to try to
lock you up that's what they wanted to
do yeah you know or libido yeah
lobotomize you yeah let's just take your
brain out yeah right up right so having
mental problems with some serious [ __ ]
back then nowadays called mental health
we're gonna go talk to a counselor that
you didn't do that back then that was
that was that's what I was serious
that was some serious problems there was
something wrong with you and so that's
why I think this movie was really ahead
of its time because she is like a
sympathetic protagonist you know it's
not like I was gonna compare it a little
bit to like Roman Polanski's repulsion
but she is clearly seen as like a crazy
person and murders people and stuff like
yeah in this one jessica is you can tell
she's really struggling and she
trying to fit back in you know and the
thing of an you know every perception
that she have is going to be questioned
and she knows that I mean people with
mental health issues in these movies
were the monsters yeah basically the
monsters of the movies right so what I
guess they still are today I mean you
know in some minor but like I said this
movie really ahead of its time one of
the best depictions of like mental
illness I said that didn't make her seem
crazy or didn't make her seem like a bad
guy or a monster it made her very
sympathetic particularly like I said
because you could hear a lot of her
internal monologue now so as I said they
pull up to the house and they see you
know this girl on the porch and she
thinks it's just her seeing things so
she doesn't say anything about it so
then they go in the house and then she
sees like the this woman in white again
and she's like oh [ __ ] like there it is
he I'm seeing [ __ ] again but her husband
sees at this time too so it's a real
person so she's like host okay the
crisis averted this is a real person
this person is Emily now she says that
oh wow I thought the house was abandoned
I've just been wandering around and I
was squatting here so she's like super
pretty shallow a redheaded and she's
kind of a hippie like free spirit type
so jessica is like she knows that woody
the friend that they brought with them
is kind of like ooh lady so you know
what I mean so she's like well why don't
you stay for dinner you know you don't
have to go and everything like that so
they invite her to stay now here's an
interesting aspect of this maybe I know
it's like 70s and these people just be
hippies and stuff like that but Jessica
not only notices that their friend woody
who's younger than they are is into
Emily she also notices that her husband
is into Emily and instead she gets kind
of upset about it but not she's almost
kind of like interest interested to see
where it's going to go like what's going
to happen so she ends up actually
inviting Emily to live with them
to live with all of them this because
it's a big [ __ ] giant house and it
was actually filmed in an actual house
in Connecticut and it's really creepy
and spooky and everything like that so
they asked Emily to stay with them now
as it turns out while they're kind of
like messing around
and cleaning stuff up and they're
looking for some stuff some antiques
that they can sell in town you know just
to make some extra money and stuff
because Duncan has given up his job
essentially to come out here in the
middle of nowhere and be a farmer and
[ __ ] like that you know for for her to
get better because he thinks that will
help her so they're going through the
antiques and stuff and now up in the
attic there's this really interesting
like really pretty like silver frame and
it's got this photograph at the bishop
family and the bishop family used to
live in this house so when they go to
the antique dealer to try to get some
money for it he's like oh yeah the
bishop family they used to live in that
house that you're in you know Abigail
bishop you know she was in a wedding
dress like in um in the picture
he's like yeah she never got to wear
that dress on her wedding day because
she drowned like the day before the you
know right in the pond like next to your
house and they never found the body and
so they said so around here people say
that she never died and that she's a
vampire and she's still like lurking
around somewhere so um so jessica is
like fascinated by this [ __ ] she's like
no way like tell me more about cuz like
I said she's very death-obsessed and
kind of morbid but her husband is like
man you don't tell her about that kind
of [ __ ] she's crazy enough so there's no
type of thing so so that whole thing
happens now why you see the picture of
Abigail bush'
bishop in the you know in the photograph
clearly it's Emily and you know so you
know that this woman is a vampire now
another creepy thing that happens too is
that when they go back from the antique
shop and they get back in their hearse
or whatever when they go back to the
hearse all the local townspeople who all
seem to be like old men they're all
standing around the car and they're all
wearing bandages in various places like
around there like they have bandage on
their neck or they have a bandage on
their arm or something like that and
Jessica notices issues like one they all
have a bandages on that's funny but
they're all like super hostile like
toward them they're like standing around
the car like blocking them and it's like
look at what these hippies are driving
above one so so there's that whole thing
- it's like so there's all these old
guys in town and they're like all
bandages on and they hate us and they
don't want us to be there and all this
other kind of stuff so generational
differences yeah I guess so and like I
said they don't look like hippies
they're not like over like peace and
love man
like normal people a lot of those
hippies digits oh they're normal people
videos from Woodstock yeah they didn't
look all not all of them were
stereotypical not like actually a lot of
do that kiss from is just regular 60s
Tony act like [ __ ] and [ __ ] jet you
know the next shot which is the same
it's funny to me that like it seemed
like such a huge like fashion difference
cuz like to me they it they didn't look
weird yeah it's not like the Halloween
costumes you see if like 60s hippie yeah
no nobody looks like that well some of
them kind of did for certain for certain
like was Woodstock footage yeah guys up
front the ones that are really trippin
out they didn't actually talk about the
the Halloween costumes no they know many
people that dressed like it'd be like
Sonny and Cher back then yeah and they
and then that was over-the-top
they're over-the-top I mean the people
breaking in Charles Bronson when he
wasn't working him and his looking
badass girlfriend all right and
everything outfit if you guys don't you
guys stick a Charlie Charlie Bronson is
this grizzly old man when he was young
he was in good shape and that dude was a
cure dresser he did he bail bond sharp
yeah I wouldn't wear a shirt just have
dinner the short vest yeah and I didn't
know that Charles Bronson was physically
a badass he was he was stacked he had a
lot of muscle yeah that could be back 20
min and then his prime he had a
badass-looking wife to she's
good-looking remember her who was that
she was another celebrity she was a
celebrity actress yeah well you know
Bronson man I'm gonna go back and
revisit Bronson I'm going to collect
some Bronson movies Bronson movie yeah
Bronson yeah told Charlie yeah yeah so
okay so at this stage Jessica is pretty
sure that Emily is a vampire or that she
is at least a you know Abigail Bishop or
she's a ghost of a Bo Bishop or
something like that
but again she doesn't want to tell
anybody because they'll think she's a
nutcase now the interesting thing too
about Emily's character is that there's
so much like really cool like subtle
[ __ ] going on in this that not only is
Emily like a physical vampire she isn't
fangs or anything like that but she will
like cut your neck and drink your blood
and stuff and she's immortal and
everything but she is also an emotional
vampire
in the sense that she moves into this
house you know with them and just
systematically starts to shut Jessica
out she seduces her husband and takes
him away he cheats on her you know so
she very systematically inserts herself
into their lives and gets them to all
and there's like a couple of really
great scenes in there were like they're
all sitting around the table and Jessica
is just sitting there with and the three
of them are all like laughing and joking
and stuff like that and she's just over
there with her like internal monologue
and then she's like I can't you know I'm
going to bed and stuff so they they're
like slowly she's slowly getting rid of
Jessica you know what I mean
but then the thing - and this is where
it kind of reminds me of Carmela a lot
is that she also has kind of a seduction
against Jessica - so like you know the
two of them go swimming and she pushes
her like Emily pushes Jessica into the
water and then like pushes or under and
then she's like touching her like all
seductively and stuff so there's that
whole aspect to like again that's the
thing that reminds him Carmela the whole
lesbian vampire thing yeah like what I
was gonna say yeah and all that stuff is
like based on countess Bathory really
yeah no I think was a countess Bathory
spin-off yeah it was it was that's who
he used as an inspiration for the
character and there was a lot of like I
said there was a lot of lesbian vampire
movies in this late 60s early 70s
including like I said daughters of
Darkness which I probably want to do a
review on that one of these days because
they were like mixed on carmela it's a
good mix you know back in the day people
like - vampire movies and they like
lesbians yeah when is everybody yeah any
like and that that folded right in with
Bathory because bathrooms she was about
that yeah yeah and that's the same kind
of thing that happens here so there's
also this kind of seduction going on and
as I said you know that scene where
they're both at the lake and she's like
doing this kind of stuff and then and
then she disappears and jessica is like
looking around the lake and she's gone
and then all of a sudden this creepy you
know Emily comes back out of the water
like in
wedding dress which obviously wasn't
what she was wearing before she was
wearing a bathing suit before and comes
like creeping out of the water but you
don't know if that really happened or if
jessica is just imagining it like
obviously she's not imagining Emily
Emily is really there but is Jessica
imagining that Emily is a vampire is she
imagining her looking like Abigail
Bishop you know it are people just
putting this stuff in her head you don't
know and she doesn't know and that's
what's kind of like so you can kind of
sympathize with her like freaking out
because she doesn't know what's going on
either so and then something happens
where she keeps seeing this other girl
like this girl in like a white nightgown
like running around in a graveyard and
stuff again she thinks she's just
imagining it she thinks she's just a
ghost but she sees her in a graveyard
one that she follows her and the girl
shows her the body of the antique dealer
he's like laying at the bottom of this
cliff and he's all covered with blood
and [ __ ] like that she's like flipping
out so then she goes and finds her
husband now her husband sees the girl in
the nightgown so that's a real person
but when she takes her husband back to
where the body of the antique dealer was
it's gone and then later on they see the
antique dealer alive again like walking
around in town so it could be yes that
emily is really a vampire and she's just
taking blood from them and then they're
getting up and walking around again
because they're like on dead or whatever
or it could be that she's imagining all
of this like I said the movie spoiler
alert never tells you Jessica doesn't
know and you don't know she even says
like at the beginning of it because she
does get away Duncan gets killed woody
gets killed you know pretty much
everybody dies except for her but she
kind of she manages to escape and then
like gets in a rowboat and then she's
out in the middle of the lake and then
she looks back and she sees Abigail or
Emily and like all the other towns folk
like the old guys like standing there on
the shore like looking at her so you
don't know and that's another thing too
you don't know if she like actually
escaped if there's anything or you know
that like I said there's this whole
isolation thing yeah and she even makes
a statement I think it's even the
beginning in the end it might like
bookend the scene my book and the movie
where she's talking about you know
dreams nightmare
she did you know madness sanity I don't
know which is which anymore and that's
how they kind of end up on it so you
don't know if all this really happened
if it was all in her head if some of it
was in her head or what
so as I said that's something that I
really like about these types of movies
where you're not sure you know it has
like a paranoia thing too because you
know you know like Rosemary's Baby or
something like that where you think
everybody's against you but you don't
know if you're just imagining it so
there's that whole thing going on to
know I've noticed was that watching a
movie it really did how you perceived
that movie really depends upon your mood
well yeah I was watching this you know I
mean it really wasn't quite in the mood
see when you do this kind of stuff for a
living our schedules tight we got to
watch movies for a living here we gotta
go to theater you know I mean it's
almost like a full-time job and the
chances of us both being in this in the
same mood to watch the same movie you
know I mean sometimes we won't either
one or one of us one of the other of us
is gonna kind of off and I was kind of
off when I was watching this one yeah
had I been more in the mood for a 70s
vampire style slow-burning type movie I
probably would enjoyed it more yeah but
like I said it's a this is a specialty
yeah I mean this is yes 70s vampire type
stuff is is a specialty thing you know
but I think I would have enjoyed him but
had I seen it in a better mood any
better and again this is one you know
yes you have to definitely be in the
mood for like a slow burn like I said
it's a very dreamlike you know it
doesn't have like a lot of action it
doesn't like gore it's one that you
really have to pay attention to like a
lot of the subtleties of like what
Jessica's internal monologue is saying
like what their facial expressions are
you know the conversations that they're
having because a lot of it is just
subtext so it's one of those ones where
you really kind of have to be in the
mood and you have to like pay attention
to you know the acting and how they're
interacting with each other because
that's where a lot of the story is going
on now oh go ahead on a subject of
vampires there we have a subscriber and
friend
Sophie and she sent me a couple of
blu-rays and one of them was was from
called Dracula untold and that was just
a couple of years just a couple years
old and it was it's from that legendary
studio studio is called legendary yes
anyone that did 300 we're gonna do a
review of that one too that that one
there man blew me away I really liked
that one I really liked it too I liked
it a lot more than I thought yeah
because they didn't they didn't stick to
that 300 and you know motif were there
but slow motion stuff you know yeah they
did in the very beginning during the
monologue I thought it was gonna
continue doing that as like oh man not
another one of these but no it perfectly
captured it's just a good premise yeah
how did Dracula become a vampire and
what did he do with it when he first got
it you know and it shows him defeating
the Turks as a vampire neat man really
neat movie so we're gonna do a review of
that one too yeah we definitely yeah
we'll do a full review on that so yes
since we're talking about vampire much
yeah but like I said this movie you know
this is just one that I remembered from
my childhood because I saw it a lot on
cable when I was growing up and I
remember it creeping me out
um you know again it's a very slow burn
very dreamlike but if you like that type
of thing and like I said in a way it's
like really ahead of its time a lot of
kind of tropes that came along later in
the 70s were kind of utilized here for
maybe not the first time but you know
one of the first few times and I feel
like this movie really kind of it got
decent reviews at the time you know most
people said it you know did fairly well
at the box office but it just then it
just kind of like disappeared
I think lately it's kind of gotten a
little bit more of like a cult following
but even so I heard that the blu-ray
release it didn't even have any extras
on it or anything like that it just had
the movie and there's you know the movie
looks beautiful they've restored it but
it doesn't have any like supplemental
material really during that time a lot
of stuff was coming out and it was
getting better and better yeah you know
so it probably just one of those movies
that came out got a theatrical release
vanished
yes VHS really wasn't a big deal it
didn't in the 70s you know you VHS went
there yeah you could most people
couldn't afford a VHS player until the
eighties yeah
and you have to think too that
particularly in the early 70s when this
came out I mean I kind of feel like a
lot of the like creepy slow-burn haunted
house movies that was more like late 70s
it seems like early 70s was more like
exploitation or like schlock or like
over-the-top like shocking gory stuff
with Last House on the Left um you know
Wes Craven this very famous movie like
[ __ ] like that and Texas Chainsaw
Massacre so I feel like this kind of
slipped under the radar a little bit
maybe maybe if it had come out later in
the 70s maybe people would remember it
more also remember what the world was
like back then yeah movie was shown in
the theater and then it vanished you
never saw it again yeah because it
wasn't cable in the 70s yeah and there
what well until the very late 70s and
there wasn't VHS or Betamax yeah in
widespread you know circulation so a
movie was shown and then if it didn't
really blow people away it would have
been forgotten yeah wasn't until you
know cable and that's where I think I
first saw this one and that would have
probably been the early 80s I'm thinking
because like I said we had cable
starting from 1980 or 1981 and they and
they showed like a lot of you know we
had all the pay channels and stuff so I
feel like that's probably where I saw
this one maybe I saw time like us a
notice or something we had cable before
we had a VHS player we did - yeah you
know and you're the early VH say if he a
chess players huge well we had a Betamax
burger yeah they're like a thousand
bucks
they were thousand bucks back then so
that yak 2500 today they weren't cheap
yeah they were soo I couldn't have won
the movies were saved I couldn't afford
my own personal VHS player until mmm 91
yeah in the army
no they dropped down to probably $130
yeah I think people forget it's like
ever so expensive like ever in the
eighties yeah I mean we always we had to
like buy them used or like yeah and then
like seems like a you and then like a
year later you could get a TV with a v8
with a VCR connected to it for about a
hundred dollars yeah and that was that
was like mind-blowing I know I remember
being very excited wow you know I could
watch a movie you know that's all
here you know it's all in one piece yes
and it's gonna be HST that was still
expensive it's like 50 bucks yeah 30
bucks maybe for a movie but we rented
him yeah we need Blockbuster yeah well
and like I said we didn't even have
Blockbuster where I grew up until later
we had Movie Gallery yeah that was like
kind of a it's a different era
lower-tier saying a lot of movies that
came out in the in the in the early part
of the seventies a lot of my thing kind
of just got lost
yeah didn't show them on cable you
weren't gonna see him again now it's
stuck out there I'm sure that is good
that we don't know the name of it yeah
exactly I mean like I said the only
reason I remembered this one one cuz
it's a great title even though it sounds
more like it which should be an
exploitation movie but the more I
thought about it I'm like the more I
like that title because it implies the
title implies that they're like on some
kind of campaign just to yeah it's a
like gas lighter yeah well you know what
I mean so I think that's like an
interesting choice that that that might
have made more sense from a marketing
standpoint maybe because at that but in
that particular year vampires were kind
of like a badge on rrah yeah they
weren't selling well and like I said
only marginally in the entire movie it
doesn't have all the vampire movies
right that's what you did is you sold it
with a title that reminded the public of
another movie they had a title that was
kind of like that and that was salad
yeah cuz like I said it sounded more it
almost sounded more like like a murder
movie early a thriller type of thing
probably because that's what was pop in
that year and I think that's why and I
always remembered it like I remembered
like the creepy scene of her coming out
of the water and like some of the other
creepy scenes and I always remember the
title so I'm just really glad that it's
kind of seems to have gotten like a
critical reexamination like I said it
did alright at the time but it really
got kind of a cult following I just kind
of read a smattering of like different
horror sites today of different reviews
and most of them just I can't get enough
of like you know pray of praising it and
it also ended up when they did I think
it was time out in London when they did
they pulled like all these horror
filmmakers and writers and stuff like
that like - for them to pay
their scariest hundred movies or
something and this was actually ended up
being on there I think it was number 85
or 86 or something like that so this is
something that clearly a lot of people
remember fondly just like I do so
hopefully at some stage it will get like
a more if they can find like any
supplemental materials about it that
would be great
that they could put on a blu-ray because
like I said it has been restored but the
blu-ray doesn't have anything extra on
it except for the movie but you know so
if you have not seen it you should
probably go check it out let's scare
Jessica to death from 1971 it's on
shudder right now I'm not sure where
else you can get it but I'm sure there's
probably other places so go check it out
if you're into that kind of thing and
that will do it for this latest movie
retrospective remember if you liked the
show like share subscribe on all your
social media it really does help a lot
if you'd like to financially support the
show you can do that too you can go to
our patreon page patreon.com/lenguin